j'entends plein de trucs sur l'année
prochaine
[Rires]
Évelyne Thomas j'ai entendu de tout
alors j'ai vu aujourd'hui Ségolène Royal
que j'adore j'adore qui était avec moi
sur une nouvelle émission politique
après sur C8 pour l'instant c'est ton
walking progresse on est dessus ça peut
arriver
ça peut arriver
deux j'ai vu que j'arrivais l'année
prochaine à 19h45 non
[Rires]
19h40 voire même peut-être un peu plus
tôt
voilà ça c'est clair d'ailleurs demain
je serai là dès 18h
BIM ça file bam bams BIM BIM OK et ça
donne tout l'oseille
[Rires]
on s'adore on discute pour l'instant pas
du tout voilà on parle on a d'autres
j'adore la boîte j'ai eu un crush voilà
et pour le début
voilà pour l'instant c'est si toutes les
meufs pour qui j'avais un crush
travailler avec moi
autre chose donc là il reste deux jours
les chéris
on va en chier ça
on va en chier des bulles carrées je
vous le dis ça va être chaud parce que
c'est vrai que là tu vois tous les soirs
c'est quand je fais pas l'émission je me
dis à 18h qu'est-ce que je me fais chier
d'ailleurs l'année prochaine je serai
même là tous les vendredis
dès le début c'est bien ça
dès le début
[Rires]
voilà pour le trajet voilà c'est
important
[Rires]
tous les jours lundi vendredi et
peut-être après peut-être un jour dans
le week-end ah ouais
à tout de suite mais en cours de l'année
dimanche on va voir vous allez voir vous
inquiétez pas on bosse dimanche en hiver
donc je serai là je serai encore plus
présent qu'avant
[Rires]
je suis payé et je vous le jure que
c'est vrai et je le dis au
téléspectateurs que je fasse une
émission ou 10 émissions par semaine je
suis payé pareil ah mais je vous jure ça
ne change rien ça dépend du pareil
je vous jure que c'est vrai c'est vrai
je vous jure que c'est vrai ça ne change
rien ça ne change rien alors que nous
aussi alors que nous aussi il y aura il
y aura une nouvelle émission
40 une vraie émission sera plus en
best-of et donc moi j'arriverai à 18h40
salut les gars habillé BIM en vedette
pas comme ça on vedette
américaine
et donc 18h 18h15
je peux pas encore lui dire je sais pas
encore j'ai pas encore décidé
et moi j'arrive à 18h40 et là j'envoie
du pâté